this is another one of my tips in
language learning and I'm going to start
out by showing you the book that I wrote
the linguist the personal guide to
language learning also available in
Chinese
and at that time about 20 years ago I
spoke nine languages and a major theme
of my language journey and in that book
was the joy the enjoyment that I had
from my language learning from
discovering languages from discovering
more about people and so forth and so on
no one can make you enjoy a language
however if you don't enjoy the language
and if you don't enjoy learning the
language you probably won't succeed you
have to find a way to enjoy it you have
to find you know the types of learning
that you like uh content that you like
voices that you like people that you
like you have to focus your efforts on
finding a way to enjoy the language and
the process of learning the language if
you do that you will succeed absolutely
guaranteed